[Musique]
je voulais faire bouger les lignes
je suis partout sur cette chaîne je dois
avoir mon mot à dire dans les décisions
qu'on prend ici ce que tu demandes la
c'est
alors je suis sans précédent
tu as très envie de devenir associé mais
ce n'est pas ton tour Alex n'oublie pas
de fermer la porte en partant
3 2 1 3
on est plus à l'antenne tu sais ce qui
se passe avec un pirate toute notre
système éteignez cette musique
a été victime d'une cyberattaque cette
attaque elle est nucléaire certaines
choses pourraient être divulguées
et chose personnelle qui n'avait pas
vocation à être partagée qu'il fasse
futé ce qu'ils veulent oublier n'a rien
fait pour me protéger
c'est vrai mais moi oui
nous approchons dangereusement de la
faillite c'est un désastre il nous faut
quelqu'un qui soit plus riche que Crésus
moi ce que je t'offre c'est une bouée de
sauvetage prend l'argent
tu es sûr de le connaître ce gars
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire tu te rends
compte de ce qui est dans le jeu
tu as une chance de pouvoir
crédit
j'ai trouvé ça plaisante de me faire
poignarder dans l'estomac plutôt que
dans le dos merci
il a 20 ans comme tout le monde en
direct
[Musique]
tandis que c'était là tu veux prendre
les commandes
c'est que j'ai fait une grosse erreur
mais c'est bon je gère
toutes les règles comment peux-tu encore
t'asseoir dans ce fauteuil en direct
tous les soirs
il est temps de tout mettre à feu et à
sang faisant tout péter
il faut finir ce qu'on a commencé
[Musique]